our next guest is a Golden Globe and
Emmy nominated actresses whose go-to
karaoke song is you ought to know by
Alanis Morissette that is not an easy
song to sing but I will tell you she is
the it gal in Hollywood please welcome
Caitlyn Deaver
[Applause]
s
here I am so thrilled to meet you I have
been watching you and everything for the
last few years
it's so nice to be here and to see all
of you and to meet you for the first
time this is so nice okay so I just saw
a ticket to Paradise because uh George
Clooney
um he's gonna be on our show uh and
you're so wonderful in the movie oh
thank you it was a it was a dream truly
it was a dream
um getting that call
um saying that that I'm I'm gonna be
George Clooney and Julia Roberts's
daughter is is just like
foreign
it's so overwhelming I mean like one of
them is a lot and then like two of them
is just insane
um it's just my it's mind-blowing
um and the two of them I have to tell
you like their friendship is is just the
best thing to be around it's the best
energy it's um they love making each
other laugh it's truly the best
[Applause]
um
is it true that you guys went on like a
sunset boat ride in Italy with George
it was it we were in Australia still
shooting the movie so Boat Boat Ride
George Boat George
Australia on a tiny little island we
were shooting on an island that was
literally like three miles wide three
miles long and you it was so small you
couldn't even drive a car so you were
like literally driving golf carts around
this tiny little island people would
pass by George on his golf cart and it's
just the the craziest like world we were
living in but yes he took us on a he
took the cast on a casual Sunset boat
ride and the boat was really nice and he
he and a mall were hosting us with like
tiny little ham sandwiches and just the
most insane thing I've ever done and
then they took us back and they we all
got back in our golf carts once we went
got back to land and like we followed
them back to their house and they hosted
us even longer with some pizza that they
had just made it was
crazy
it was I don't even know like when I say
that out loud I can't even process that
well
um another genre you're tackling is
Rosalind which is I freaked out on the
log line first of all it's written by
the guys who wrote 500 Days of Summer so
let's just start with that right
um and it is a I mean you explain it I'm
so excited I want to like tell it for
you so we all yes we all know Romeo and
Juliet the tale Romeo and Juliet
basically the story of Rosalind is about
the girl Romeo was dating just before
just right before he met Juliet and
Rosalind decides to sort of convince
Juliet along the way that Romeo is not
the guy for her because Rosalind is
supposed to be with with Romeo so
um I'm really excited about it but we
have a clip oh yeah take a look I'm so
excited for this you've never heard such
poetry
let me guess
he Compares you to the Moon and the Sun
fairest stars in heaven do and treat
your eyes
[Music]
how
how do you Romeo Montague isn't it
and um Last Story may I ask is it true
that like Tom Hanks
let you hold his Golden Globe yes but
what did he say that's what I love to do
oh my God he just I honestly can't
really my parents will remember it
better because I probably blacked out
right
um I couldn't I couldn't I couldn't even
think straight but he we were passing by
each other and he stopped me
and he handed me his Golden Globe and he
said just just doesn't that feel nice
someday you'll be holding one of those
and I'm just like crying it was so crazy
it was really really sweet well I'm so
happy for your beautiful career I'm such
a fan of yours and I'm so excited to
meet you today it's so great to meet you
drew
thank you
thank you from now on Hulu and don't
forget to catch tickets to paradise and
let yourself like walk out with the most
open-heart and open mind about love
because that's in theaters this Friday
[Music]
foreign